hello chess fans i'm sam copeland and
i'm a national master on the content
team here at chess.com
i'm here today to show you an amazing
computer chess game
played between stoffles and stockfish in
the chess.com computer championship
number 15. in this game stockfish plays
like the great
paul morphy gambiting a pawn in the
opening
and following up with an amazing attack
that delivers checkmate in
only 24 moves nearly unheard of in an
engine tournament
the game begins with a book move from
the tournament b3 the nemzo larson
attack
this is also one of hikaru nakamura's
favorite opening moves
in fact on chess.com it is his best
scoring opening move
after b3 white obviously intends bishop
b2 with pressure on the dark squares in
the middle of the board
therefore e5 from stockfish is the most
challenging response
it says i know you're trying to attack
the dark squares in the center of the
board
and i'm still going to build my pawn
center there come and get me
after pawn to e5 we see bishop b2 and
knight c6
i think c4 here is already inaccurate
basically white is playing a b6 sicilian
and the b6 sicilian is the worst
of the sicilians even the extra move
with the white pieces is not going to
redeem it
instead in this position grandmasters
like hikaru like to play pawn to e3
now the kind of main line here and a
semi-famous line
is knight to f6 bishop to b5 threatening
to trade on c6 and win e5
bishop d6 is an awkward defensive e5 but
it does develop the bishop
and knight to a3 moves the knight to the
edge of the board to get it to c4
pressuring d6 and e5 the most popular
move here is the irrational move
knight to aa5 also moving to the edge of
the board
to stop white from putting the knight on
c4 this position is extremely weird
very irrational but it is actually about
balanced
instead in the game after c4 we see a
very strong idea from stockfish to put
pressure on white
that is the move knight g to e7
for a human player this is very
unintuitive
why would i want to block in the bishop
here on f8
the idea turns out to be to break d5 as
soon as possible
even if you have to sacrifice the pawn
in e5 to do so
in this case the knight is actually
going to be well placed on e7
because sometimes it needs to get to c6
to maintain compensation
the game continues knight f3 and
stockfish follows through with the idea
of the sacrifice
pawn to d5 now white can either accept
the pawn on e5
right away or after exchanging on d5
if you accept right away we see why the
knight needs access to c6
we get a trade here and after the bishop
takes back first you play d4
when the pawn is really strong and it
cuts off the bishop's retreat
after d4 basically any move is going to
be met by knight c6
the knight is really strong here putting
pressure on the bishop and defending
this
pawn basically in all cases black is
going to get
really good counter play the bishops
develop quickly and the heavy pieces
rapidly reach the center of the board
and exert a lot of pressure on the white
position
in the game we do see the trade on d5
first and then the acceptance of the
gambite pawn
so c takes d5 knight takes d5
knight takes e5 knight takes bishop
takes and
once again stockfish shows a real
disdain for this bishop
queen to e7 for the second time a piece
is put on the e7 square
blocking in the bishop but this bishop
on e5 is attacked the queen is putting
pressure on the king on e1 actually
and also this bishop is going to soon
move and black is going to rapidly
castle queenside with a lot of pressure
that's exactly what happens the bishop
falls back to b2
and now night before with a huge threat
of course
an engine is not going to miss the
threat but a human white
might well not notice that knight d3
mate was a threat
in this position instead after knight to
b4
we see the move pawn to e3 which does
stop the threatened smothered mate
and now bishop f5 threatening knight c2
check knight to a3 is virtually forced
in response
and now castles at this point stockfish
is basically developed with the queen
the bishop the knight
these pieces aren't in yet but they will
be in soon
there's certainly a lot of pressure here
and the idea of knight d3 check is
very strong one response and maybe the
best response would be d4
expanding in the middle of the board and
stopping knight to d3 check
after queen g5 stockfish has really good
compensation
but it's not clear that black is winning
or anything like that
instead though we see stuffles play the
move bishop c3
this is a very human error it's
basically
overthinking the position it comes up
with an idea
the idea that if you play knight d3
check now
after a trade here and then knight c4
the knight can make it to b2
for example f6 and b2 you can chase away
this bishop and white is actually okay
here
however just because you have this idea
with bishop c3
doesn't mean you can really justify a
move that wastes time
when your opponent has already
sacrificed and has so much pressure
and so in this position we see knight to
d5
creating two very serious threats knight
takes c3
and queen takes a3 after knight d5
we actually see the losing move forced
here was knight b5 when black has a
really good position
but maybe no win instead after the move
bishop b2
stepping back there is a forced win from
stockfish
pause your video and see if you can find
it
the brilliant and crushing move here is
knight
takes e3 this knight sacrifice
absolutely destroys the white position
there is no defense however stockfish
still needs some beautiful
and instructive moves to finish things
off now
the knight sacrifice must be accepted if
you try to grovel with queenie 2
then the queen trade will not save you
the bishop is going to hop into d3
and after the attack rook moves there is
bishop c5
a rook is going to reach the e file with
devastating effect
so after knight takes e3 we do see the
acceptance of the knight's sacrifice and
the ideas queen h4 check
and the king cannot go to e2 because of
maiden 1 with bishop g4
so after queen h4 we see g3 and then
queen to e4
the rook on h1 is attacked and only has
the g1 square
now bishop b4 developing with two
threats
the threat to capture on d2 with either
the bishop or the rook
and the threat to capture on e3 only one
move defends both squares
that is the move knight to c4 in this
position
pause your video again to try and play
like stockfish
and like paul morphy in this position
stockfish plays the brilliant rook takes
d2 this move vividly recalls paul
morphy's great rook takes d7 from the
opera game
in fact throughout this game i find
stockfish's play
reminiscent of morphes it is sacrificial
open
and natural attacking play after rook
takes d2 we see knight takes d2
and just like morphy stockfish takes the
time to bring in the other rook
rook to d8 there are now two threats a
thread on d2
and also a threat of queen takes e3 and
queen takes g2
the only way to defend both threats is
rook to g2 here
now after queen takes e3 i really feel
like the game should have ended with
rookie 2.
in this position there is only one
winning move
it is the queen sacrifice rook takes d2
again after rook takes e3 there is rook
takes b2
with a monstrous discovered check the
only way to get out of the check
ultimately is to give back the queen on
d2
after bishop takes d2 and then bishop
captures e3 black is winning on material
in the game we actually saw bishop e2
but this
just allows black to capture on d2 now
it might actually look like
even though you're going to lose the
queen you might not be doing too badly
on material for white
but in fact black's queen and the
bishops just shred the white position
it's over very quickly king f1
rook takes d1 and then bishop h3 pinning
this rook on g2
there are huge threats here and it's
just desperation from white
bishop g4 captures on g4 rook to d8
just giving up a rook in a spike check
and after king takes and bishop d4
it is actually mate with queen to e1 and
checkmate
this is move 24 to get checkmated for an
engine and only 24 moves
is nearly unheard of i really hope that
you've enjoyed this game
as much as i have if you haven't seen it
yet i encourage you to check out the
opera game
in the links that are popping up on your
screen right now and be
sure to check out more great games from
stockfish in those same links as well